but a lot of a lot of people are toxic
now like it's it's a norm like it's
actually a normal you're not toxic
they're confused like I'm not I'm being
so serious like why haven't you cheated
on me yet that is like what no it's not
because you know what it's real it's
just like what Pearl said earlier like
when I do the street interviews and I
literally have to say this every show
like this is a setup I'll be like I
really have do you have a toxic X yes I
I don't even need to ask I just say
let's talk about your toxic ex that's
how I should start it now yeah and I'd
be like oh well he was toxic how long
was he with him oh three years five
years eight years 15 years on and off